a vertical milling tool sculpts a recess
in the blank to seat an o-ring sealer
then swishing bits the Machine contours
the outside of the blank taking it from
rectangular to round other tools carve a
large hole in the center and profile the
inner diameter so that the part will
mate to the tank this ring is designed
to be removable to access the tank for
maintenance here's the blank before and
after machining like powerful cookie
cutters computerized punches cut out
numerous parts from an aluminum sheet
they include the oil tank body the top
and other assembly pieces to make the
tank body cylindrical a worker turns a
crank to curl it around a roller this
tank body is called the rapper
a worker welds the tank ring to the
bottom cone creating a thick seam all
the way around
[Music]
he then seals the seam of the
cylindrical wrapper body and welds a top
cap to a de-rating baffle air will rise
through it and vent it into and out of a
side chamber leaving only oil in the
tank he fits an adapter ring to the
upper lip of the tank and taps it down
with a rubber mallet a worker now taps
perforated plastic inserts into holes in
the air vent chamber these inserts will
both vent and filter the air from the
tank he fits a rubber sealing ring
around the fill neck and screws the cap
on he applies adhesive back decals to
the tank for branding purposes
[Music]
he caps the oil inlet tube to keep
contaminants out during shipping he
turns the tank upside down and installs
a valve on the bottom of the vent tank
[Music]
he inserts a rubber o-ring into a groove
on the base of the tank wall and tucks
it into place all the way around
[Music]
after equipping the fittings on the cone
with caps for shipping he installs the
code on the base of the tank and screws
the ring tightly to it accessing the
tank for maintenance reasons will mean
unscrewing this part that completes this
race car oil tank
hooked up to a system of pumps these
tanks will receive and dispense oil
sparingly to improve engine performance
they've been well equipped for life in
the fast lane
[Music]